fifteen years before his movie a lot of
things have changed in the petrol
landscape but one of the things was sort
of derek zoolander gave us the the
selfie face I guess he did though he
existed before the selfie actually
existed I mean when we made the first
movie there was no phone cameras didn't
really exist because I remember they
sort of emerged about 11 11 years ago we
made movie 14 years ago so but he it
felt like Derek needed a camera in front
of his face because the look that he
does is basically the look that people
seem to do when they take a selfie now
but Bernie even you do it now me yeah
like what I do it I do it yeah well
lately because we've been doing the
movie and or we'll go to a premiere so I
got people say hey can you do blue
stealer people look so I'm just like
trained to do it and then somebody will
say hey can you take a picture and I'll
just do the what are you doing that it's
like I'm just like a trained animal do
you get awesome because you didn't do
blue steel but do you get ask for blue
steel oh I do and I would try for a
couple years to say but that's not my
character and then I just gave up and I
started doing my blue stick let's see it
please well mine is a sound this is a
set everybody has a blue steel that's
like fingerprints but give me a
countdown 1 3 2 1 go when you breathe
down
pout or is it up a jaw it's it's a
combination of it's really a visit Titan
okay okay okay okay